みなさん、ここのダガンさん、日本の財政に関して
本当に簡単なことを明確にしたい
と思います。
これは、
日本に住んでいる多くのアメリカ人にとって非常
に重要
かもしれません。
私がここに持っているのは、
いわばシステムを経由するのではなく、日本で自分の仕事をし
ている
ということです。
海外に住むアメリカ人として投資することを学び
ました。この男から
オンラインで無料でダウンロードできることを知りましたが、日本での
仕事のビデオで私がお勧めしたことの1つは、いわばシステムを介して仕事をするの
ではなく
、 日本の会社で、
そこで翻訳者のようであるか、
そこでプログラマーである私は
、自分で何かをするためにフリーランスに行く
こと
を勧めました。 日本のビデオで
私はあなた
が日本で約10万ドルを稼ぐすべてのお金は
日本で課税されるのでIRSによって課税されないだろう
と言いましたそしてあなたはIによって
課税されるためにそのしきい値を超えなければなりませ
ん はアメリカ
政府
によるものですが、私が本当に迅速に明確にする必要があるものがいくつかあります。
これは
、IIが
後で税金の問題に見舞われることを望まないためですが、
申し訳ありませんが、前に正しいページにたどり着いたはずです。
ですから、ここ
で説明します。これは、その方法で最も明白になると思うので、読み上げます。
ただし、投資家は非常に注意する
必要がありますが、投資家は、
これらのアカウントを管理する複雑なルールを回避するために、非常に注意深くナビゲートする必要があります。
不必要な
課税を引き起こしたり、税金の
繰り延べステータスを失ったりする可能性のある間違い
は、これらのアカウントの税制上の利点をさらに最適化するために
、
課税対象と税金の間で株式と債券の投資がどのように割り当てられるかを慎重に計算する必要があります 米国が課す税制の
ため、自営業
の退職貯蓄口座の適切な使用のための繰延口座または免税口座は
特に重要
です。 アメリカ人
は、
米国以外の収入源から得られる自営業者の収入を持つアメリカ人に米国が課す税制のため、
一般的に米国以外の雇用者によって海外で雇用されているアメリカ人は、
自営業税を完全に免れることができますが
、自営業のスケジュールで海外に住んでいるアメリカ人は誰でも
Cの収入は
、二国間合計協定によって免除されない限り、Lexに15ポイント3％の税金を支払う必要があります。
したがって、私の
理解では
、日本で自分の会社を立ち上げ
、日本に会社がない場合、IIは
私のお金を受け取ります。 グーグルから、そして私
はパトレオンから、そして先に述べたようにヤフーのように私のお金を得る
ので、そのお金のすべては
私が日本で始めた独立した会社への収入として来ていません
、そしてまた私は私の
税金をに報告します 米国政府は
、プロの認定を受けた
プロの税務会計機関を通じて、
海外に住むアメリカ人のために前述したグリーンバックの税務会社を通じてIRSを行うことを強く
お勧めします。
個人的にはこの問題に遭遇したことはありません
が、私が明確にしておきたいのは、会社を経由する
よりも独立して働くことが最善
だと思うという
ことです。あなたは先に進むことができると思います。
ただし
、独立して仕事をしている場合は
、詳細を指定するつもりはありませ
ん。状況ごとに異なるため
、この15.3％の自営業税が課せられる可能性があり
ます。
日本で
起業する外国で起業する場合、
他にもたくさんの問題
があることを理解しているので
、日本で起業することはお勧めできません。
独立した労働者
は海外に住む独立したアメリカ人の対象となる可能性があるため、税金を正しく報告していることを確認
してください。
これもすぐに読みますが
、
自営業の収入がある海外に住むアメリカ人は支払う必要があります。 米国
から
ではなく、米国からではない収入の15.3％が全額
です。したがって、海外に住むアメリカ人
であるが、会社で働いている場合は
、私がお金を払うことを心配する必要はありません。
最大10万ドルは
基本的に失礼しますが
、会社で働いていない場合は状況
が少し異なるので、簡単に
まとめると、日本で
自営業をするのが最善だと信じていることを皆さんに知ってもらいたいと思います。
それが
私がパトレオンを通過し、
YouTubeを通過し、最近ツイッチ
を通過し、申し訳ありませんがyahooを通過し
ます。ただし、独立して働いている
場合は、追加の自営業税が課せられる可能性があり
ます。
状況はあなたが
あなたの税金を正しく報告していることを確認してください。
あなたは何も戻って来て
後であなたを尻に噛みたくないので
本質的に私が言おうとしていることですので
あなたの税金を報告するために通過するのに良い場所
は グリーンバック k
私が使用している税務サービス
過去3年間、毎年使用しているので
、
このような突然のビデオ
についてお詫び申し上げます。
過去に行ったアドバイスですので
、税金を正しく報告していることを確認してください。
新しい仕事をするときは、必ず専門の税務専門家に相談してください。引き続きサポートし
ていただき、ありがとうございます。
さようならまたお話しするのを楽しみにしています